comme elle je sais que votre mère a une
place très importante dans votre vie et
votre carrière vous lui devez beaucoup
ouais je vous propose qu'on la fasse
venir pour l'interview là ok
[Musique]
alors madame si là bonjour bienvenue
c'est votre première télé ont du sens un
peu un peu stressé mais tout va bien se
passer rassurez vous un stressé pourquoi
s'intéresser à moi je suis pas stressé
c'est toi qui es stressé rigueur qui est
tout blanc
on passe à l'interview fils à maman
[Musique]
même si vous fait plaisir vous retrouvez
ainsi comme ça à côté de votre mère
ouais ouais c'est mon rayon de soleil ah
oui à un rayon dans tout le sol est la
moins chère est on si tu veux des tutti
dit la moitié la moitié c'est bien ma
mère c'est un début sur les lacets bien
là ça réchauffe le coeur
ahmed on peut le dire votre temps à
jouer un rôle immense dans votre
parcours vous lui devez énormément ouais
moi je pense que je lui dois tout ouais
non c'est bien il a bien répondu à la
question suivante
si c'est quel genre de mère votre main
merci une vraie maman poule sauf que moi
je ne pense pas désert
de toute façon manqué j'ai fait des
blagues personnes rigole à m qu'est ce
que vous lui avait jamais dit à votre
maman vous aimeriez lui dire ce soir
j'aimerais lui dire maman je t'aime mais
arrête d'essayer de faire des vannes
laisse moi faire c'est mon métier
madame si là vous auriez aimé qu'il
fasse quoi comme métier ahmed bon déjà
j'aurais aimé qu'il fasse un métier
parce que ça c'est pas un métier ça
c'est pour rigoler déjà c'est de la
rigolade c'est comme notre président
c'est pas son métier c'est pour faire
rigoler déjà vos parents ils sont fiers
de vous aujourd'hui quand même non
huawei sur l'île sont ils sont très
fiers de moi ma mère allait elle est
quand même très fier de ce que je fais
mon père il est il est très fier de ce
que je gagne
j'ai fait des études mais a eu le bac
bien bien après le bac vous est lancé
plus sérieusement dans l'humour vous
avait percé grâce à on n'demande qu'à en
rire l'émission de laurent ruquier il a
été comme une deuxième maman pour vous
ça je le savais je t'avais dit laurent
briquet c'est une fille ah ça c'est
savez ce qui vous a pris l'eau laurent
ruquier m'a il m'a beaucoup appris mais
surtout beaucoup inspiré grâce à lui
j'ai arrêté les jeux de mots
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
faire rire aux débats mais amélie l'aîné
daul a mené les medal son corps il n'
roll à 1600 mhz quand il aimait manger
quand il est pris dans mes bras je n'ai
pas pleuré ah non j'ai rigolé en fait
c'est simple c'est la meilleure blague
de son père
s'annonce plutôt bien pour vous un aigle
et fit j'imagine que c'est l'autoroute
cette rumeur entre nabila et vous c'est
quoi je suis toujours en vie
vous voyez où dans cinq ans dans un
miroir
de toute façon ma quand j'ai fait des
blagues personnes ricol a programmé ce
soir merci beaucoup c'est un excellent
la mission les gens
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux